[Music]
standalone tournament additions of FIFA
such as 2014 FIFA World Cup Brazil are
often overlooked in favor of a year it
came to parts however World Cup Brazil
comes with more than enough content and
ideas justify this existence as a game
in its own right although to what extent
depends on how you're currently
fulfilling your people needs while
there's a nice array of new passing
shooting and jostling animations the
core mechanics driving the action on the
field lack the finesse and depth of the
ps4 and xbox one fifa 14 experience this
rings especially true when you're
defending with a large AI unable to deal
with players boasting a combination of
raw pace and accuracy of shooting in
practice this creates a game that feels
more fun than it does realistic offering
an experience that is markedly different
from that of FIFA 14 shooting in
particular has been made more accessible
a well struck ball flies through the air
as though tethered to a guided missile
making the taking of long-range potshots
a more viable option than it has been in
recent years invariably this leads to
some spectacular looking attempts on
goal which naturally leads to
spectacular goals in a bid to counter
the venom of shooting goalie seem to
have been given an ability boost novice
able to prevent the scoreline from
getting out of hand it's also much more
difficult to score from corners
thanks to the new over the back headers
players can now employ rather than
simply standing limp and lifeless as an
attacker cut in front to score with his
head at the near post defenders can now
jump up using the shoulders of anyone in
their way in a desperate attempt to get
their head to the fault
first any and all these gameplay tweaks
would be rendered useless without
sufficient content within which to make
use of them captain your country and
road to the FIFA World Cup are the most
robust an exhaustive game mode to
conquer joining the obvious inclusions
of the World Cup tournament itself and
the essential set of online and offline
exhibition matches all 203 officially
recognized FIFA national teams are
included and available for your
selection allowing you to undo the
injustice associated with the likes of
Sweden and Poland failing to qualify for
this summer's part of
what makes World Cup Brazil a genuinely
different proposition to other recent
FIFA titles is the care and dedication
that's gone into the little details that
manages that shouting command from the
sidelines cutaways to fans celebrating
goals in front of screens in their home
country unfortunately the graphical
quality of the crowds remains as
terrible as they've ever been on ps3 and
xbox360 but at least there's more
variety this time around it's best to
consider 2014 FIFA World Cup Brazil is a
less serious or accessible accompaniment
to the main feeder series focus more on
giving players a good climb than it is
on driving the quest for realism and
sports games this is a football game
that's perfect the fans that are looking
for a way to pass the hours between
World Cup matches this summer beyond
that it may not be as exhaustive as the
likes of FIFA 14 but with its own
distinct feel and modes to explore
there's more than enough here to keep
you satisfied before FIFA 15 lands later
in the year
[Music]